Speaker Nancy Pelosi facing new
questions about how much control she has
over her own party this comes after a
week of infighting about an anti hate
resolution that the House passed
yesterday some Democrats have said that
the final measure did not mention Ilhan
Omar by name following her recent
comments that are being called
anti-semitic and an apparent dig at the
freshman lawmaker a senior House
Democrat telling Fox News quote all of
our problems are caused by three people
House Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy
blasting Pelosi for failing to rein in
her new members he need to mark it as
the moment that the new Democrat
socialist wing of the party overtook
their own leadership the socialist grip
could not be tighter this isn't the
Democratic Party that we've come to know
the transition is now complete that the
Democrat socialist wing of the party
controls their own leadership it's
interesting Brian that Nancy Pelosi
really owes her speakership not to these
new firebrands the the freshmen that are
making all the noise and the news but to
the moderates that won in swing
districts and beat those Republicans are
having a tough time but now it's like
the only one that can get attention are
the freshman members that are making a
lot of noise it's unbelievable because
in the beginning it was like look how
powerful she is look who the Comanche
has and look at how Paul Ryan dropped
the ball and then they thought well is
she gonna be able to go to the middle to
make sure those moderates keep those
seats and now the story is how did she
get this so out of control where it
needed 48 hours just to have a
resolution that would say anti-semitism
is wrong now we had a resolution that
said everything we learned in first
grade still holds don't be mean to
people and now we have a situation where
somebody they actually told us did these
freshmen this Minnesota freshman in
particular Omar when she came out and
said oh by the way I'm gonna need you to
change the rules because I'm gonna be
wearing this headdress so hundred
eighty-one years I'm no one was allowed
to wear anything on their heads now they
can then they can go Lindsey Graham is
compromised I thought to myself what's
going on here and then we find out about
all these other past tweets and our
apologies and backtracking and then you
see a situation where no one can rein
them in I thought she chose in the
beginning not to now I realize she can't
yeah ELISA has it gotten away from them
like this is like basically a defining
moment or do you think that now that
they've gotten past this
that they can pull things back together
well I don't think they've really gone
past it because the resolution was a
joke right and even Democrats criticized
it like represented euch who is a Jewish
Democrat
called his party out for failing to
specifically distress address the
anti-semitism but to your point earlier
Nancy Pelosi is facing this big
challenge because there's no doubt that
the party is viewing towards the left
you look at something like Medicare for
all
which Bernie Sanders introduced during
the 2016 election that was once
considered outside of the mainstream now
it's a mainstream part of the Democratic
Party and you see the frontrunner for
the 2020 presidential election embracing
and it's almost a litmus test you look
at things like the green New Deal you
look at extreme stances on abortion so
the party is certainly going to the left
and the problem for Democrats which you
pointed out Dana is a lot of these
moderate Democrat members who represent
Republican leading districts who could
be in jeopardy in 2020 and also
alienating independence vote independent
voters heading into 2020 and also some
of these Rust Belt states and critical
states that Democrats need to win but
even a Nancy Pelosi one she is tapped
the brakes on impeachment on Medicare
for all and on the green New Deal she's
basically to kind of dismissed all of
them in public comments and yet it is
what's getting all the attention well I
think that's the media but you know I
think that's a legitimate thing because
this is the controversy this is what
people are talking about to my mind that
the big slip-up here is that otherwise
we'd be discussing things like the
Republican revolt against the President
on the emergency claim for the border or
we'd be talking about the Democratic
bill HR 1 which surprised to lay out new
rules would regard to ethics and
campaigns and voting so essentially they
have run over what Pelosi wanted to be
the message at this time I will say this
I think Pelosi did a great job I don't
think she's under pressure you guys
described because she held her caucus
together she that's money I mean yeah
and it walked out she said you're not
gonna listen to me I'm gonna leave she
writes a twenty three votes Brian that
went against this resolution not one
Lisa not even people who said oh we kind
of think you should have been more
specific about Omar and about anti 70
not one Democrat voted against this the
party held together and for her that's a
major triumph because if
had split just like we're talking about
the dissension within the ranks we would
really be focused on people especially
if a Jewish member had voted against
this resolution Gregan here Oh No thank
you I'll stay out of it for now little
bird the Michael Jackson segment Hey no
I got to tell you one thing about Omar
no one is safe right she just today
slammed president a former president or
you have to sound good for it let's
listen to it as a quote sorry well then
I will do it in your voice all right
Omar says the hope and change offered by
Barack Obama was a mirage we're calling
the caging of kids at the US border and
the droning of countries around the
world on Obama's watch she argues that
the Democratic president operated within
the same fundamentally broken framework
as his Republican successor and said we
can't be only upset with Trump his
policies are bad but many of the people
who came before him also had really bad
policies they were just more polished
than he was Omar says all right so back
to what I was saying Michael Jackson
like no one is safe including President
Obama she slammed President Obama
doesn't she know that is our job
what are you there's turf in this place
and she's coming in on our turf look uh
this is what they did that was which was
hilarious and clever what the Democrats
did okay she does something wrong she
has a litany of anti-semitic slurs
instead of acknowledging it and putting
her name up there like they did with
like the Republican state with Steve
King they threw it into a bucket of
other wrongs which dilutes the actual
condemnation I think we know that that's
the obvious strategy by by inserting it
with other kinds of of hate hate crimes
and hate thoughts and so on and so on so
she kind of got it's like taking a
bruised apple at a farmers market and
putting in a pile of other Bruce apples
they all look the same that's what they
tried to do nobody likes everybody
that's clever I think it's not win for
her no no it's like it's a flat-out win
for her no it was it's I'll tell you why
it's clever it's clever because then you
have the Republicans saying okay dad
they can point to you and go you
Republicans didn't vote for an anti
eight bill
you must really be haters so it was a
nice little it's a nice little it was
jujitsu is that what it is but here's
the
I find interesting it's it's amazing how
traditionally liberal the right is now
and how right-wing old-school right-wing
the left is because you have Republicans
considering I mean condemning
anti-semitism fighting for free speech
on campus peace talks in North Korea
meanwhile the Dems can't agree on
anti-semitism they won a cold war with
Russia again North Korea and the Saudis
and they want to shut down dialogue on
campus we have a totally flip-flop world
yeah are going after Obama or defending
they want to get another topic in
because House Democrats aren't the only
ones divided the 2020 presidential
hopefuls are also split over what the
party's vision of America should be the
latest progressive shift comes from
Elizabeth Warren announcing a proposal
to catch time script scuse me to break
up big tech giants including Google
Facebook and Amazon Warren claims they
are monopolies with too much power Brian
she's like she's she doesn't care about
the Pocahontas stuff she's like I'm
putting policies on the table right very
interesting policies uh break up the
successful companies and make sure
they're not they're not successful I
don't know what she's gonna go on
legally to break up Google because there
is Bing we don't use it you did they're
just not as good so I don't know it
takes me the most successful thing about
America and then destroy it that's a
good way wouldn't way to run being that
Kamala Harris wants to legalize
prostitution she can't do that
or legalize pot cory booker had that or
medicare free preschool Sanders has that
she's got to pick out something else
that makes her unique I just don't think
this is going to resonate with anyone
who has someone respect for the free
market you know who people should be
looking at and people aren't giving him
enough attention is Bernie Sanders he is
the only Democrat who's thrown his name
in the Hat that is generating an
excitement on the Left you're seeing it
was genuine though yeah well exactly and
unlike all these other people he comes
across as authentic as well and I think
when you have such a crime a private
crowded primary field unique situations
happen I think there's very much a
plausible situation where Bernie Sanders
is the one that emerges but as the
front-runner in the Democratic Party
Greg did you get any credit for doing
something that they have no one else has
done when she's like here our specific
policy proposals I just don't you know
what she she's all about co-opting
someone else's character first it was
Cherokee now it's a OC I think that she
is that she is trying to be a Oh see
that's funny because she was in Long
Island City today making this announced
thinking her husband for being in their
house well I think it's it's very
difficult for the Democrats because
initially they were very Pro these high
tech firms because the high tech firms
give a lot of money to the Democrats
very supportive but you know what when
it comes to issues and we've seen this
this week with Facebook they're looking
at the privacy rules they're trying to
revamp especially after 20 will have
their amended enlarge and so I think
you're wrong Brian I think there are
lots of people in this country who say
you've got to regulate you see the
Europeans already saying these high-tech
companies right now are running over our
societies that make an attack regularly
no responsibility regularly sure about
following the Europeans right off a
cliff